(audience applause)
I am here with the ultimate...
Oh, you've got your cup!
Ray of sunshine! Rachel Ray!
(applause)
Yes, Rich Cervini's Angels. Hi, Rich.
Hi, Rich Cervini. He's a producer on our show,
Both Rachel and I,
and he's a very important figure in our life.
So cheers to him.
And Rachel had these made for us. So thank you again.
I'm so happy you have it.
By the way, I just saw John pass through.
Yeah, he's here.
Hi John!
You mean the crew?
Hey, Drew!
(audience coos)
I am the underpaid, sorely underpaid crew. Hi.
Okay. Well, that's funny John, that you're here
because we're taking a trip down memory lane
about milestones and memories in Rachel's life.
And guess what? Here's where we're headed next:
2005, you marry your husband John in Tuscany!
Oh!
(audience cheers)
I remember that!
Drew, that year, that year
John and I got married in Tuscany.
John's first word was more.
My first word was Vino.
More wine. You get married in Tuscany.
Also that year
we got Isaboo.
We adopted our doggie.
That's us 10 years later. That was our 10th.
We got remarried on our 10th
and Isaboo walked me down the aisle.
Isaboo we lost this year.
Just before we lost our home, we lost our dog,
but she made it 15 and a half years.
She had a good, long dong life.
And our show is not just 15 seasons, 15 years.
Everything started the same year, the magazine, the show
our marriage...
The pots, the pans.
The pots, the pans, the brand, our foundation..
The dog food.
and the dog, everything.
everything started in that year.
That was a big year.
It was a big year.
That's funny because let's go to the next timeline please.
2006, the Rachel Ray show premiers!
Yes!
And that is the start of everything...
Of everything.
just said!
The dog, the... everything. And that...
you remember the first day of the show?
Yeah.
I cut my finger off? Just like food network.
Everything -
Every first day at food network...
You set Emeril's set on fire-
Six or seven years... Well, after I said he's set on fire.
when I had my own show, the first day of my show
I cut my fingertip off this,
by the way, she cuts her fingers off -
And then I did it again.
At least once a month.
And I wasn't cooking, I was just talking
with my hands and I hacked the same finger off
but I thought it was good luck.
I should have gone to medical school
because she needs me to sew her fingertips on, like...
Oh.
We just took such an amazing Drew the years
of Rachel and John -
I love it!
And your life together -
Woo!
And Isaboo.
And Bella Blue is your new dog, is that right?
Yes. Bella Blue Boo -
Yes, she is.
is our new dog. She's 80 pounds. Eight zero.
Whoa!
She's so big.
She's huge. She's not a year old.
She's like 10, 11 months ish. And she's the largest animal.
I think we've ever known.
Yeah.
She's a small donkey.
She takes up the majority of our bed.
And we have a big, we have an event.
Mutt Ville is a senior dog.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, member they were on the show that sweet couple?
They were the best.
Yeah, we're doing a big thing online, June,
a couple of days where we're trying
to get senior dogs adopted
and all of the dogs that are adopted
we do all of their medical, take care of their medical
get them up to, up to snuff and woof.
And we give them a year's worth of our food, our food...
What is it? How much have we done now?
Over $60 million,
$60 million dollars of food
(audience cheers)
(Drew cheers and claps)
Yes! Yes!
And we use money for animals
Yes, nutritious, a huge phenomenon.
$15 billion dollars, and we use money for animals
and people is as fast as we can, as fast as we make it.
We give it away.
Well we're celebrating meat week
all week here on the show
and vegetarian and veganism, whichever you like.
And I know you have a new treat for dogs
that they'll love right?
Well, yeah, well, we constantly make new things
in our line, and to explain to people the quality of it
I eat it often on camera just to show people it's made
with human quality ingredients.
But the newest one is for big dogs
which-
Which we're familiar with.
This is very fortuitous because it's a huge job
but we make food for every diet of dog.
And we make pots, pans, furniture
for every price tag and every type of cook.
And, you know, we just like to do things
at the lowest
benefit for us possible.
We take the smallest amount-
Yeah
(laughs)
For ourselves and we, we try,
we really use our businesses to
generate what's way more fun,
philanthropy and and making lives better for everybody,
and that's been our mission since day one.
And you do in every single way, in every single category.
And I just, I can't love getting to hang out
with both of you today more.
I wanna see you in person!
When we're allowed.
I love you guys.
(upbeat music)